as as from two days ago it's not it's
under 118. so 118 uh babies that have
been born and i presently have
14 ladies pregnant at the moment
[Music]
what is an unlicensed sperm donor uh
unlicensed sperm donor um
normally as people think of sperm donors
uh
think of the uh some man going to
the nhs a clinic producing the sperm
into a container
and they use it to um
for our ivf treatment um and it's done
through the nhs
uh whereas with me um i'm an unlicensed
sperm donor i do it um outside
and using my main medium is through
facebook
how did you get into it i read a story
uh of a sperm donor uh and i thought how
awful for the for
these people touching myself that want
children and then they just come to the
stop
where you know you can't get can't go
any further
unless you go through the clinics which
is it can cost many thousands of pounds
so so that's what got me thinking
take me through the process of becoming
a sperm donor on facebook for the first
time
i first decided i was going to go about
it now the
first decision i wasn't going to be a
natural insemination
sex or i wasn't going to do it by
artificial insemination which
you know abbreviated to ai i decided
straight away well it'll have to be ai
one reason is being married when you
when you're married you don't have sex
with other partners well i i discovered
a site
um on facebook and i say anybody can
go onto these sites i put an ad in
maybe nerves i kept it quite short of a
sperm known available in derby
um you know get in touch
i was actually at home with the wife at
the time sat on the settee to watch
telly
and and within a few seconds what we're
watching i i
totally forgot and the phone went i
picked it up it was a message
the wife was sat right next to me clive
you know i've got a a
a positive opk you know ovulation
can you get around to derby tonight so
how did you tell your wife that you
wanted to become a sperm donor
um well i didn't um
i i i i did actually
over a meal talked about how i'd read
this article
about being a sperm donor and and i
thought that's something i could do just
to see
initially what her reaction and straight
away from her reaction i thought
this is going this is not going to work
and i i just dropped it oh
it's just an idea uh and and just left
it at that and i thought
no yeah i i can't tell her so i kept it
a secret
were you nervous the first time you were
going toward your first donation
i'd i'm not that nervous no i mean what
could possibly go wrong
you know i mean it starts it's not
really it's not illegal
you know the worst that can happen is i
turn the car around and go back home
and say sorry i can't do it so um
so i wasn't so uh yeah there was a there
was some nerves there but
no i wasn't that nervous so you drive to
the place you pull up outside
have you produced the sample yet no no
no no because i mean
you want it to be fresh i mean
apparently semen is good for an hour or
two
but it seems you know but obviously i
i'm i'm keen that it's used fairly
quickly it just seems to me the fresher
it is
the more potent it's going to be because
i'm driven by success
so what i do is i'll do it from the van
that is
i will drive uh toward to
close to the recipient's house just a
street away
i'd pull up i'll uh message
have a ride just put them at ease that
you know it's really going to happen
because
a lot of donors do let recipients down
uh locked doors
jump in the back and then i've got a
curtain down it's a van
a combi a vauxhall combi uh a pull pull
the curtain down
and then i'm completely enclosed inside
because there's no windows to turn to my
van
and uh pulled the laptop out
and uh and then and then i'll have my
syringe at the ready
is uh keep them in here
i get the um syringes off ebay
that goes on there and then obviously
you don't want the stuff dripping out so
uh suck it up there into this syringe
there
mock it a bit so it's all down there to
get rid of the air because apparently
air kills seaming off
tissue cloth the tissue there's a bit of
white there wrapped up in the tissue
and then back under my arm to keep it
warm and then
um open door off i go
to drop it off bang bang hi
there you are good luck i mean sometimes
i've handed it over and walked away i
thought
you know they might have wanted to have
a word with me
said something you know i just it just
gets so uh
routine sometimes you are yeah and i'm
walking away
you hand the statement over to the to
the woman yeah and then she then takes
the syringe
yes and uses the syringe yes that's her
so you just literally
leave for that that's it that's i say
yes i mean you know i mean no no
there's two people and i'm not sure
exactly how the insemination takes place
i mean in some ways i sometimes wonder
whether the partners
actually sort of liked us because of
their father i don't know
can you remember your first time someone
texts you to say that they were pregnant
oh yes i can remember someone yeah it
was
a sunday afternoon and all the family it
was in the background
and uh the mobile went and
clive mine didn't work
but my partners did what what it was it
was a couple where they were both
ovulating at the same time
and they said could you help both of us
out and i thought
well i won't give them one syringe
because they'll fight over the syringe
so i
i produced my donation into two syringes
and gave them one each and
and and it did work for them so i got
this message this afternoon clive clive
and pregnant and
yeah i mean i remember that afternoon
nine years ago uh quite well thinking
crikey
it's like it's like be you know 57
becoming a dad again
i mean that's when it hit home this is
real stuff
you know this is this is really
happening how many
children have you fathered as from two
days ago
it's not it's 118 so 118
uh babies that have been born and i
presently have 14 ladies pregnant
at the moment does it feel strange to
know that out there there are
you have 118 children
no no no no no no i mean when i started
out
i thought that you know that there'd be
you know it might work and
you know it could be in a few years i
might think you know four or five kids
around the place that i'm responsible
for
uh being involved with i mean it's more
of the case of feeling proud
to have helped with that many you know
118.
uh that's yeah that's that's good that's
good that is 118.
but no yeah just get used to it
is it legal to provide sperm
for donation it is it it it is
it is all it is all legal yeah i mean a
lot of people say it shouldn't be
but it's perfectly what is illegal is to
charge
uh i can charge for expenses you know
the petrol
um and i charge them so you know i want
no only for the petrol and also it's
going to cost you me a hotel over the
night not
ever stay in the hotel but some do but
after that no it's quite legal
when did your wife find out uh i left my
i left my mobile light lying around
and i think i did it unconsciously on
purpose
for her to find out but i i got back
home one day and she says i know what
you're doing
i was thinking crikey i better not i i
what is she talking about you know
because you know
um and the letter said i i know you've
been
you know uh this donator oh yeah yeah uh
donating so
i believe i was doing the right i know i
was doing the right thing
i mean a lot of people won't appreciate
the difficulties
it's very simplistic to some people you
don't lie to your wife in fact
if you lie you're a liar and liars are
bad people
i've had a friend you know point that
out to me
and what were the repercussions of that
none did she would did she accept it in
the end
well this there's two choices isn't that
i mean one is
she she kicks me out or she accepts it
and
and and it was like it had been accepted
very
very unhappy about it but uh
you know what it
was the right thing i mean what is the
problem
there's not a danger you could be asked
to someone who claimed child support
against you
technically there could be the child
support agency could be chasing me for
118
um children yes financial support
but um it doesn't happen i mean these
ladies
the that i've helped were really really
desperate to have a baby
and there's no way anyone else is going
to get involved
with their baby um because if they went
to child support
i mean if i ended up supporting that
child even if in a small way
that would give me rights uh to have
that i can then turn around says
okay then five days for you i'll come
out i'll come in weekends
that's that's not that's not going to
happen so yeah if
if any recipient went down that route
child support then
they'll be giving up rights on their
child um
but but technically it is there i mean
one reason for doing this um
this uh this interview was uh hopefully
more men will volunteer to be donors
because
you know there's a lot of recipients a
lot later wanting babies but we just
haven't
enough donors i i've learned not to talk
to people about it i mean i
i say i've said i've i'm proud about it
and i feel someone to tell people oh
yeah this is just great what i'm doing
but
i mustn't because uh mo you know
eight nine out of ten people are very
very negative about it
and i've had a few mothers come back to
me and says clive clive you are going to
stop now
um you know i'm just thinking well i'm
going to tell my son or
uh your bash number 89 you know
and there's you've oh and by the way
you've got lots of brothers and sisters
out there and we must introduce you some
time to to some of them
um but um
i think a lot of mothers initially are
concerned about that but you know
these children or you know boy girl if
they meet each other and have babies of
their own you know
they're going to produce monsters you
know and they can marry each other
um in my case that's unlikely to happen
because the the
the mothers have got a group on facebook
where they're keeping contact with each
other
in this country it's recommended uh as a
health organization this country
recommend 10 only 10
the who world health organization they
talk about something 0.2 0.2 which works
there for a population this country of
300.
it's it's an emotional thing you know
how many is too many because
you know provided they're not marrying
each other you know
i can't really see the problem when will
you stop
well well i think i'm really looking at
me very soon
65. um i can see it going 250
but not much more mainly through
siblings what i have said
that i will help out for siblings so
now i'm just donating to the mothers
that have helped in the past
and and there are some that i've been
donating to for like a year and they've
still not been successful and i said
i'll i'll
i'll i'll stick with you uh so i'm
i'm i'm slowing down i i i can be asked
why did i become a donor and i mean i
thought well yeah i've got the time to
do it i've got the incentive but also i
thought hey
you know there's some good dna i mean
look at me 65
you know hang gliding you know mountain
biking very very healthy
very very fortunate i know it's not
going to last uh
and yeah health wise yeah i i'd like to
share
this dna that i've got you know through
other babies
i think i'm good dna and i'd like to you
know share that
then they've got two activated hand
grenades in my hands which
i didn't know what it means activated or
anything he says
you hold this tight and if you let it go
you blow yourself and you blow the rest
of your family